So we learned a lot about outliers and outlier rejection.
Rejection is what you're going to do to clean up your fit, but
if you're into anomaly detection or under fraud detection,
you reject the good data points, and you look at the outliers.
Either way, a really great algorithm that can be looped on
any machine algorithm is first train,
then remove the points with the largest error, often called the residual error.
And for the remaining points, you re-train.
And if you so wish, you could repeat these removal and re-train procedure.
But you normally converge to a much,
much better solution than if you kept all the original data.
And as I said before, the fraction of data you often remove is something in
the order of 10%, but it might vary from application to application.
So correlations, you know about outlier rejection,
a really important tool in the arsenal of machine learning algorithms.